the biden administration pushes global
corporate tax increases while ramping up
spending and taxation at home
the white house signals more bullying of
corporations to come and republicans are
optimistic about 2022 i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
slash event we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first here is your
reminder you should be saving a lot of
money on your cell phone bill
your cell phone bill right now is way
too high but many of my listeners have
already found out you can save tons of
money simply by switching over
to puretalk usa thousands of customers
are canceling the nation's largest
wireless providers because they found
out they can get the same service
at half the price by switching over to
puretalk that's right instead of
charging you obscene fees to pay for
their massive mainstream media campaigns
corporate campuses retail outlets across
the country puretalk passes the savings
on to you directly the average family
saves over 800
a year it's a lot of money and switching
is really easy you can keep your phone
keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids right now you can get
unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and if you go over on the data they're
not going to charge you for it so what
exactly are you waiting for
a lot of these big wireless companies
they'll overcharge you by saying you
need unlimited data you don't what you
need is that unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for 30 bucks a month
especially because if you go over pure
talk usa ain't going to charge you from
your cell phones i'll pound 250 say ben
shapiro you'll save 50
off your very first month that is pound
two five zero say ben shapiro to get
started
today alrighty so joe biden's
world-changing plans
are a pace democrats are now preparing a
wide variety
of tax increases see there's this weird
idea out there that democrats raise
spending and then they have to raise
taxes
that is incorrect democrats want to
raise taxes they like
raising taxes higher taxes are part of
the goal they think that higher taxes
lead to redistributive equality equity
can only be achieved
through redistribution of income even if
it means that overall people make less
money
barack obama said this very openly in
2008 he was asked in the middle of a
democratic primary debate
if you raise the corporate tax rate and
if that results in less revenue to the
government because the because the
economy shrinks
would you still be in favor of raising
the corporate tax rate and barack obama
said
i would for purposes of firearms it is
not
about maximizing economic growth it is
not about making america a better place
to live
is simply about punishing people for
earning and punishing corporations
and punishing anybody who runs a
business because the idea is that the
government is supposed to take care of
you the government is god in this
iteration
and because the government is god the
government is there to provide you with
a fair and just outcome even if that
means
that some people have to get punished
unjustly in order to achieve that fairer
outcome
according to the new york times the
biden administration and top democrats
in congress began detailing plans for
significant changes to how the united
states and other countries tax
multinational corporations
as they look for ways to raise revenues
and finance president biden's two
trillion dollar infrastructure proposal
now remember this infrastructure
proposal is a complete boondoggle
five percent of it is about roads and
bridges the rest of it is about a bunch
of giveaways to unions
the rest of it is a bunch of waste fraud
a bunch of nonsense that the government
wants to pay for
they've been lying they've been saying
that it's going to create 19 million
jobs that is not true
according to cnn moody's did not
estimate the infrastructure proposal
will create 19 million jobs they
estimated the economy will add about 19
million jobs between q4 2020 and q4 2030
if the infrastructure proposal gets
passed and 16.3 million jobs if it does
not get passed so
in other words it's going to add
theoretically about 3 million jobs but
that's assuming that there isn't a
massive economic downturn due to
inflation because you keep
pumping money into the economy and
everybody understands here that when you
blow out the debt the way that joe biden
is doing i mean we're spending more
money than has ever been spent in human
history
it is that simple more money than has
ever been spent in the entire history of
humanity
when you do that somebody's gonna have
to foot the bill typically the people
who foot the bill are people with
savings
because you inflate the currency and
people who earn more money are going to
have taxes raised upon them and then
they simply will not hire people they
simply will not grow their business
how much money are we spending congress
has doled out according to reason
magazine
four trillion dollars in response to the
coveted pandemic the u.s national debt
held by the public is currently 22
trillion dollars
about 67 000 per citizen that surpasses
the country's annual gdp for the first
time since world war ii
on the current path the cbo predicted in
march the debt would grow to 102
of gdp by the end of 21 2021 to 107
by 2031 and 202 percent by two by 2051.
it also predicted that by 2051 the
federal government will be spending more
than a quarter of the annual budget just
to pay interest
on the principal all of that was before
joe biden signed a nearly 2 trillion
coven 19 relief bill and before he
started pushing another
two trillion dollar infrastructure plan
what is the risk to the us economy
according to reason magazine
in 2010 midway through the first term of
president barack obama and on the heels
of the great recession the national debt
was skyrocketing
it had exploded under president bush who
engaged the us in two foreign wars and
expanded elder care entitlements which
found the biggest drivers of us debt
the tea party rose to prominence writing
a wave of public concern over debt
levels that they said would hinder
economic progress and stick future
generations with the bill
republicans claim to be renewing their
commitment to fiscal responsibility post
bush
after democrats lost president obama
established the simpson bulls commission
which concluded that disaster was
inevitable
unless the federal government started
cutting the spending and raising taxes
and reforming entitlements then they
just ignored all of this
well now say say a couple of
of scholars now they say that the
the situation is significantly worse
significantly worse than it was then
jason furman who shared the council of
economic advisers under president obama
he says he and lauren summer they now
say they've co-authored a paper
together questioning past assumptions
about the national debt
he says the debt hawks of the 2010s were
worried were wrong to worry that
america's balance sheet endangered the
economy but as the industrialized world
racked up debt through the 2010s
inflation and interest rates stayed low
the situation
said furman and summers implies the u.s
government has much more leeway to
borrow
furman says the story is still the same
here but john cochran at the stanford
university hoover institution disagrees
he says if you wait until the crisis
comes
everything is much much worse so in in
other words
people are starting to believe that we
can just suspend the laws of economics
permanently that is not correct
even lauren summers who helped author
that study saying that we're not
spending too much money now he says
we're spending too much money
debt projections right now are probably
too low
they're probably significantly too low
okay so they're going to raise taxes and
they're going to raise taxes massively
and this is what they're interested in
doing
here's the problem the minute that you
start raising taxes
you start driving corporations out
multinational corporations simply move
out of the united states we had a bunch
of reverse organizations
of major american companies during the
obama administration when companies
that were sort of partially organized
here and partially organized abroad
simply reversed course and organized
abroad instead
because the tax rates were lower there
so the democratic party simply denies
this they simply deny economic realities
you can spend money endlessly through
modern monetary theory and also
if you raise taxes on people they won't
leave now obviously this is untrue
if you raise taxes on people they will
leave one of the reasons people have
been leaving california for places like
florida and texas
is because there's no state income tax
in florida and texas i speak as somebody
who left california
in large measure because of the state
income tax in california but joe biden
is out there saying things that are
abjectly untrue
he says there's no evidence that high
taxes drive corporations out which is
just insane
are you really afraid that the highest
tax will drive corporations
at all because there's no evidence of
that
the tax was 36 and now down to
one percent and the idea that that's
that's
bizarre we were talking about a twenty
eight percent
fact that everybody thought was just
clear enough for everybody
the idea is you have here you have 51 or
corporations of the fortune 500 haven't
paid a single penny attack for three
years
come on man come on man come on man is
joe biden's go to when he has no actual
logical counterpoint to the fact that
corporations will react
in their own economic self-interest to
protect themselves if he radically
increases the corporate tax rate
so they have decided that they're going
to come up with a new solution the biden
administration they're not just going to
raise taxes at home
they are now going to create a new world
order in which the united states works
with other european
countries to artificially boost tax
rates around the world
so if we can't get other countries if we
can't beat other countries on the tax
front we'll get them to join us
on the tax front and artificially
increase the price of doing business
which of course is not going to avail
anybody because corporations will then
move to other parts of the world they've
already been doing this they'll offshore
to places that are not in europe
they will offshore to countries that do
offer them tax havens
the notion that you can just change all
the economic incentives and nobody
changes their behavior is completely
crazy
but the goal here is to organize
essentially
a united nations of economics
you know if you wanted a new world order
the way that the biden administration is
talking is the new world order
and here is the thing right now biden is
quote unquote leading the new world
order but what happens
when other european countries raise
their corporate tax rates above the
united states as corporate tax rates and
demand that we raise our corporate tax
rates as well
and what happens when all of our
corporations decide you know what
we're out we're just gonna go to
singapore we're just gonna organize
somewhere where the tax rates are not
exorbitant
the fact that we are even talking about
this shows how ridiculous biden's
economic policy is
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact you
don't really want to go to an auto parts
store
it's not something you're super into
rockauto.com will help you avoid that
when you go to an auto parts store you
have to stand in line then finally you
get to the front of the line
then they ask you all these really
specific questions about your car you
probably don't know
and then they're like oh yeah we don't
have that part we have to order it
online or you could just go online
yourself by going to rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do why would you
spend up to twice as much
for the same parts rockauto.com is a
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years head on
over to rockauto.com
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers
why again would you spend up to twice as
much for the same exact parts it makes
no sense instead head on over to
rockauto.com check out their catalog
it's unique it's remarkably easy to
navigate you can quickly see all the
parts available for your vehicle
and you can choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need at rockauto.com head
on over to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
alrighty so the new proposal from the
biden administration is not just to
radically increase taxes on corporations
which by the way
they keep talking about multinational
corporations and we're going to punish
giant corporations
a huge percentage of small businesses
are incorporated
our llcs or inks
when he says he's not going to raise
taxes on people making under 400
thousand dollars a year you know how
many small businesses in the united
states
have people who own them who don't make
400 000 a year a lot when you raise the
corporate income tax
what you end up doing is raising taxes
on all the people who make the money
from that corporation this is going to
impact economic development right now
biden can do whatever he wants because
again right now we are an artificial
recovery because we're an artificial
depression
last year we had the greatest economy in
the last 50 years running up into covid
then covet happened get an artificial
depression
and now because of an artificial
depression we're gonna have an
artificial boost of economic growth when
everybody goes back to work
everybody on the democratic side of the
aisle knows that and so what they feel
like is
okay well we've got this tsunami of
economic growth coming that means
that we can simply float our taxation
boat on top of that economic tsunami
well
here is the problem when you change the
economy structurally there are long-term
impacts to that by the way the tax
increases that they're proposing are not
real they're proposing tax increases
that materialize over 15 years and
spending that materializes over eight
well what happens ten years from now
when nobody wants to raise those taxes
the debt just goes up but
more broadly janet yellen who was
supposed to be this moderate
jenny ellen was supposed to be this a
political figure at the head of the
federal reserve all she wanted was sort
of moderate slow inflation
slow growth in terms of the federal
reserve boosting the economy and instead
has
essentially put the fed rate down at
zero and left it there forever
janet yellen has a solution to the big
problem here which
she's tacitly acknowledging which is
that if you raise the tax rates in the
united states people leave
corporations organize elsewhere what is
her solution her solution is
a global tax a global tax
we can have a global tax regimen whereby
all the industrialized countries decide
to set a minimum tax rate
for corporations thereby forcing
corporations to pay that tax no matter
where they organize by the way first of
all you think countries are going to do
this
you really think countries are going to
do this no one's going to do this it's
ridiculous
if you are a smaller country and your
only draw is your tax rate why would you
sacrifice that because janet yellen
wants you to
you wouldn't beyond that if you
artificially increase the price of doing
business
that has some pretty mainstream effects
in the economy
if you boost the amount of tax that
corporations pay no matter where they
locate
all that's going to do is lead to price
inflation that will lead in turn to job
loss
it will lead to a lack of demand you
want to create a global depression
a pretty good way of doing that is
raising the global tax rate
beyond that once you establish the basic
notion of a global tax
who do you think is going to run that
global tax you're assuming it's always
going to be the united states making
those raids
but what happens when all the rest of
these countries they say listen you want
global tax what we really need to do is
we need to set up a council
any a global economic council and we are
collectively going to decide the tax
rates for the entire western hemisphere
we're going to do it for all the
industrialized countries so we'll just
give up the autonomy to set our own tax
rates here in the united
to work and yet states she is proposing
it all to justify a crappy
bad economic idea from joe biden that is
going to offshore jobs
we're working with g20 nations
to agree to a global minimum corporate
tax rate that can stop the race to the
bottom
together we can use a global minimum tax
to make sure the global economy thrives
based on a more level playing field in
the taxation of multinational
corporations
and spurs innovation growth and
prosperity
okay the notion of increasing a global
minimum tax as as
increasing innovation and prosperity is
nuts i mean it's nuts it's taking the
money away from the people who do the
innovation and prosperity and giving it
to governments you just blow it on
random crap
but this is her big idea and again
there's no way that once you set up the
g20 as a global taxing body
that that is not that is a one-way
ratchet you think that the g20
in the future is going to ratchet the
taxes back down so you're talking about
giving up american autonomy in the long
run because that's the only way this
works
other countries are not just going to go
along with us because we wish them to
they're going to do so if they gain
leverage
and the way they gain leverage is by
saying we need a new economic structure
in which we all get together
and set attacks together we set a tax
together basically
we are going to reverse brexit here we
are going to
increase the interconnection of all
economic policy with a bunch of
countries who have completely different
social structures
completely different spending structures
it's wild
i mean but don't worry don't worry the
the blue states in the united states
will get off easy
this is the part that's so incredible it
really is democrats are all for
increasing taxation except for their
friends
this is the part that's truly
astonishing we'll get to that in just
one second first
let's talk about making your business
better if your business is growing
zip recruiter is the way to go right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire it's really important for
companies and job seekers to be able to
connect quickly and efficiently
ziprecruiter doesn't wait for great
candidates to find you ziprecruiter
finds them for you when you post a job
on zip recruiter it gets sent out to
over 100 top job sites with one click to
increase your chances of reaching top
talent
then zip recruiter's powerful matching
technology scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right skills and
experience for your job and
actively invites them to apply so you
get qualified candidates fast
no wonder four out of five employers who
post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate within
the very first day start finding great
candidates today when you try
ziprecruiter for free
just go to this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that's ziprecruiter.com
i r d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e ziprecruiter.com
slash daily why are zipper careers
indeed the smartest way to hire that's
the reason we here at the daily wire
have been using zipper
for years and you should too
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire give them a try you're gonna
get better candidates and if you're an
employer
a prospective employee looking for a
great employer check out zip recruiter
today ziprecruiter.com
dailywire alrighty so joe biden and
company
proposing a massive tax increase in the
united states
also democrats in congress releasing
their own proposal to add teeth to the
de facto minimum tax the united states
already imposes on income earned abroad
one that would apply to american
multinational companies regardless of
what the rest of the world does
the proposal could raise as much as 1
trillion over the next 15 years from
large companies well weird because um
you know one trillion dollars over the
next 15 years you know what that doesn't
amount to four trillion dollars that
we're going to spend over the next eight
and those are just the two bills that
biden's trying to pass in the first four
months of his administration
utterly wild yellen is her support for a
global minimum tax according to the new
york times
could help catalyze an agreement being
worked out through the organization for
economic cooperation and development
which seeks to reduce companies practice
of booking profits
in low-tax haven countries to avoid
higher tax bills elsewhere
negotiators are discussing a range of
possibilities for such a plan but they
have not settled on several crucial
details including the rate
of the minimum tax the focus on raising
taxes for large companies comes as biden
begins to push to sell a 2 trillion
infrastructure plan and finance it with
higher taxes
democrats in the white house say their
goal is to ensure companies pay their
fair share
and don't move jobs and profits abroad
to avoid paying taxes in the united
states
but of course we are already taxing
corporations at a higher rate than most
european countries so we're now
encouraging all those european countries
to come along with us the only way that
works
is if they also get to control some of
our policy senator pat toomey
said that yellen's call for a global
minimum tax is an admission that biden's
plan to raise the corporate tax makes
american companies less competitive
which of course is exactly true
the moment that you say we need a global
minimum tax what you're actually saying
is that the united states is no longer
competitive
so we have to bully other countries into
doing what we want them to do
yellen says that um the
many developing and middle-income
countries are struggling financially
because of insufficient tax revenue
and that they have to tax more yes that
is definitely what developing countries
need to do tax more
just the unbelievable ridiculousness of
this that's the big problem
developing countries don't have
centralized enough governments and they
need more tax revenue that'll that'll
definitely fix the problem
you know that that was the big problem
with the soviet union their taxation
levels weren't high enough
okay but what is this is what is this
really about what this is really about
is
punishing enemies and helping allies
because the same administration
the same exact biden administration that
is currently pushing to raise taxes on
corporations
and raise tax on multinational
corporations and raise taxes on the top
tax brackets
they are trying to carve out exceptions
for their friends
so one of the little notice things about
the trump tax bill is that
if you lived in a blue state it
absolutely jacked you the trump tax bill
lowered taxes overall for some 80 of
americans who pay taxes
but what the what the trump tax bill
also did
is if you were paying a state or local
tax it was
not counted as a deduction against your
federal tax right these are called salt
deductions
they were not counted against your
federal tax so i lived in california
that meant that before state and local
taxes were taken out of my income
and then based on the remaining income i
paid federal income tax those were taken
as a tax deduction against my federal
income tax
after the trump bill they weren't right
my my gross income
was taken as the basis for both the
state and local taxes and the federal
taxes so they're basically stacked on
top of each other
okay that creates a counter incentive
for states to raise their own taxes
because now citizens of those states
are actually paying higher taxes now
what the what the democrats would like
to do
is raise the federal taxes and punish
states that have very little tax
why because they now want to basically
exempt states and localities with high
taxation
from their citizens paying higher tax
rates overall the idea is that the
federal government is going to subsidize
states and localities with high tax
rates
so just to get the math wrong but give a
brief example
let's say that you have a hundred
thousand dollar income and let's say
that you pay ten thousand dollars in
state local taxes
you now have ninety thousand dollars
left over to pay your federal income tax
and you can take the ten thousand
dollars as a tax deduction against that
right that's that was the old system
under trump's bill the one hundred
thousand dollars was used as the basis
for the ten thousand dollar state tax
and as the basis for the twenty thousand
dollar federal tax he paid thirty
000 in federal tax as opposed to paying
20 of 90 000 which is
18 000 right so instead of paying 30 000
in tax you're paying like
26 000 in tax 28 000 in tax it lowered
your basic tax burden
well the biden administration wants to
go back to
the the old tax system whereby if you're
in a blue state with a higher tax rate
you are not punished for being in a blue
state with a higher tax rate
now what's weird about this is that
these are the same people who say that
they want to fill in the debt gap
they want to they want to punish the
rich unless the rich happen to live in a
blue state in which case
those rich should be treated better than
rich people living in red states
because those red states are better run
and the last thing we would want is for
people to move from blue states to red
states
for purposes of saving on tax money
so jen sackey over at the white house
says well you know maybe we will
reinstate the blue state tax deductions
there are some that are proposing as you
all know salt deductions in other
areas that are not uh revenue raisers so
this will be all a part of the
discussion and
absolutely our economic team and number
data crunchers will be crunching numbers
as we proceed but
uh we're kind of in the early stages of
these discussions at this point so again
they want to carve out exceptions for
all of their friends
just like they want to carve out
exceptions and campaign finance reform
for big labor and just like they want to
carve out exceptions
when it comes to when it comes to you
know
virtually every other of covay they want
to they want to accept all their friends
the same thing is happening here they
want to attempt all their friends from
the new tax laws as long as they live in
blue states
why well because those states want to
raise their taxes too
and they want to reward those states for
raising their taxes new york is
currently set to raise taxes on people
earning over a million dollars so
welcome to florida
all you new yorkers are about to move
down please leave your politics back
where you okay
where they came from the purpose here is
they know that all the taxes are going
to rise in california and new york
because blue states want to raise taxes
so biden is trying to make it easier for
states to raise taxes
just like biden's trying to bully other
countries into raising their taxes
the goal here is to build back better
and what do they mean by build back
better they mean more top-down
government control they mean more
government confiscation
of private property and then use for
random payoffs to all of their friends
it is a new american order and it is a
new world order that is currently being
pursued
right a world order in which if you are
an ally of the biden administration and
the left
then you get special goodies and if you
are not then you simply get punished
okay meanwhile speaking of punishment
the
biden administration continues trying to
unofficially punish corporations for not
doing what they want so
there is some funny blowback here but
the the reality is that the biden
administration basically pushed major
companies
based in georgia and doing business in
georgia into breaking up with georgia
by lying about this georgia voting law
as i've said before it was all lies the
georgia voting law broadens the voting
hours the georgia law
broadens the ability to vote you have
more time to vote in advance of an
election it opens alternative sundays to
voting
the georgia law does not restrict voting
more people will be able to vote
in georgia more easily thanks to the new
georgia voter law
but the biden administration was lying
about it for political gain because they
want to make it seem
like georgia's red nature meaning that
it's more republican state than a
democratic state despite the last two
senate races
that that republican state is actually
discriminating against black americans
this is the lie stacey abrams has been
telling for years it's a lie that joe
biden has been telling for years and
they
triple down on that with their lies
about the georgia voting law which we've
discussed extensively on the show
jen sack at the white house was asked
about the fact that joe biden is a
damned liar about this georgia law
and she just doesn't care that's the
answer she doesn't care
the washington post gave that claim
four pinocchios because that part of the
law
gives counties the option to extend
voting hours and so i'm just curious
if the president is going to change the
way they want to talk
well fundamentally the president doesn't
believe it should be made harder
to vote but the thing he said has been
determined by
election law experts to be not true
so i'm just curious if he's going to
stop saying well
again i think we can the fact checkers
will also
tell you that this bill does not make it
easier for people across
the state of georgia to vote and that's
where he has concerns okay that is not
true first of all there are fact
checkers who have said that it makes it
easier for people to vote as
in general over prior election law in
georgia beyond that
the fact trackers have said that biden
is lying but they don't care about lying
it doesn't matter
the goal here is to punish people who
are not like joe biden who don't think
like joe biden who don't think like
democrats
hey saki said that when biden encouraged
the major league baseball
all-star game to move from georgia he
didn't even care about the economic
consequences in georgia after all george
was a red state why should he care
here is jen sackey saying he she won't
even say if biden considered the
economic consequences apparently cobb
county
is going to lose about 100 million
dollars in this deal by the way
worth noting that um georgia is a
heavily black state
and mlb is moving to a county in
colorado that's like 75 percent white
so um yeah here is gensake
before the president said that he would
strongly support moving
the all-star game out of georgia did he
consider the economic impact because
the cobb county tourism ceo is saying
they're going to lose 100 million
dollars
in lost uh business activity 8 000
hotel rooms did he think about that
before he said he would strongly support
the move
again he was doing an interview he was
given the context as i just read out to
you in full detail of how the question
was asked
he answered the question okay so what's
amazing here and we'll get to this in a
second is biden is trying to back off
this slightly because the backlash is
coming guys the backlash is coming to
all this to the new world
order nonsense the backlash is coming to
the covet hysteria nonsense the backlash
is coming to spending more money than
god
the backlash is coming to the the racial
equity bullcrap being promoted
by the by the abiding administration the
backlash is coming and it is coming
strong
but saki says we are going to punish our
enemies right there will be more efforts
like this and there should be more
efforts like this to go after
corporations and force those
corporations to get involved in politics
and if they don't mirror our politics to
punish those corporations
should we believe that if pga tour
players who are arriving in augusta
this week or today to register for the
tournament if they got together
and decided or talked about not
participating that is something he would
strongly support or is there anything
i'm sure you will ask me that question
or him this question but
our focus is on doing what we can to
advocate for making voter
voting easier and more accessible around
the country and that's where our efforts
are going to be from the white house
right so the answer is going to be yes
the white house is going to militarize
against corporations
and against anybody doing business with
states we just don't like
now of course the people who actually
benefit from doing business in these
states they're not going to actually
stop doing business in these states
right as marco rubio points out the
senator from florida
he said to rob manfred the head of mlb
um you know it's weird because i noticed
that you are a member of augusta
national
are you going to give up your membership
at augusta national he says i write to
ask you whether you intend to maintain
your membership at augusta national golf
club as you're well aware
this exclusive members-only club is
located in the state of georgia
so you are a hypocrite by the way
speaking of baseball's hypocrisy here
so they moved the game from georgia to
denver there's only one problem
georgia's new law gives you 17 days of
early voting
colorado's law gives you 15 days of
not only that according to ed morrissey
writing at hot air colorado also
requires government issued id for
in-person voting the same way that
georgia does
also it turns out that georgia
actually prevents people from giving you
stuff within a certain distance of the
ballot box
guess what so does colorado it prevents
campaign workers from giving food and
water to voters within 100 feet
if they are wearing campaign apparel
also your you
are signature required in colorado for
mail and ballots their signature
verification for mail and ballots
also again the state population in
georgia is 31.2
black and they moved the 100 million
business opportunity to a state where
4.1
percent of the population is black
or if you look at atlanta atlanta's 51
black
and um denver is 9.2 percent black
and 76 white so
so yes none of this makes any sense but
it's not meant to make sense it's meant
to be a punishment
everyone must be punished everyone must
be punished and the media are full in on
this
the biden administration is full in on
this nbc is now openly targeting
corporations
to try and force them to disassociate
from any state they don't like it's not
just georgia
brian schwartz over at cnbc a political
finance reporter
he put out a piece yesterday saying that
disney geico expedia
and other corporations backed florida
lawmakers who are now sponsoring
restrictive voting bills
since 2018 thousands of dollars have
flowed from these corporations
into the campaigns of florida lawmakers
sponsoring the bills now the idea here
is that all of these corporations are
supposed to cut off business with the
state of florida or
giving donations to any republican who
supports anything that they
that the left does not like this is all
a bully tactic
it is all designed to militarize private
industry against
people with whom the left disagrees and
it's really really gross
okay this is gonna have consequences as
we'll talk about in just one second
okay because it turns out that there is
a momentum building and it is not on the
left side of the aisle
it is not on the left side of the aisle
the worse the left gets the more there
will be a backlash right now people are
pretty sanguine about what biden is
doing because they're not following it
because he's a house plant because all
he's there to do is hide the water stain
he's a non-threatening
nearly senile old gentleman who doesn't
seem particularly mean
and the media just cover him with this
with this sycophantic slobber
and everybody kind of goes okay i guess
things are all right i mean the
economy's recovering we're going back to
work
there will be consequences to this stuff
politically we'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that when you see a home
with ugly blinds when you walk into a
home it's got bad window coverings
occasionally now you're going to now
that i've said it you're going to see it
you walk into the home you look at the
blinds and you realize this house needs
an upgrade well
look at your own house does it need an
upgrade if it does you need to check out
my friends over at blindside.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop
top quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping the experts
at blinds.com understand that window
treatments are one of the household
items you just don't think about but
they can make a huge impact on the look
and feel of your home
you don't need to do a full renovation
by simply changing what's on your
windows you can change the way light
comes into your home and that creates a
totally different feel
head on over to blinds.com just take a
look at all the options faux wood blinds
cellular roller shades
even outdoor shades if you're nervous
about trying them no reason to be
because blinds.com has helped
millions of homeowners through the
process plus they guarantee the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or have
them measure and install
everything for you go right now see how
much you can save at blinds.com
when you check out online don't forget
to tell them you heard about blinds.com
from
the ben shapiro show rules and
restrictions may apply go check them out
right now
blinds.com again upgrade the look and
feel of your home and do it in an
inexpensivewayblinds.com
okay in just a second we are going to be
getting to
covet insanity and the left's continued
focus
on generating a sort of panic feel about
covet even though
the statistics just do not justify that
sort of panic first
as you return from eastern and passover
it's important to reflect on the impact
holidays have on our faith and the
impact judeo-christian values have on
our culture
more and more the left would love to
erase those values and replace them with
their own pseudo-morality that's one
reason we've launched a brand new talk
show with candace owens she's one of the
fiercest protectors of conservative
values and free speech there is
go behind the headlines and twitter
fights and see kansas as herself
funny political insightful watch her
host lively discussion panels
and exclusive interviews with an always
exciting round of guests candace is also
the first
daily wire show to appear in front of a
live studio audience an element that's
rarely been seen in conservative media
and cements our commitment to fighting
for the culture whatever the left does
we can do better the show streams on
fridays 9 p.m eastern 8 p.m central at
dailywire.com
but you can get the audio podcast canvas
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to your podcast so
if you need some candid zones in your
podcast feed to look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify and
subscribe today
be sure to leave a five star review if
you like what you hear you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
okay other factors that are going to
lead to blowback hair so we've already
talked about the economic policies of
joe biden which are going to put an
artificial damper on what should be a
rip roaring economic
recovery here we're talking about
inflation inflation of prices we're
talking about spending money
we don't have we're talking about
raising taxes to ungodly levels and then
trying to basically build an economic
berlin wall to keep companies here
at home right all of this is bad then
you have the
the insane bullying of a white house
trying to force corporations
into doing what they want them to do
politically and you have corporations
going along with it
then you have the white house continuing
to promote this coveted insanity this
notion that covet is not on the way
over 100 million americans who have
already been vaccinated out of a
population of 330 million
that is mostly the most vulnerable
who've been vaccinated because we
started with everybody over the age of
65 in rational states and
the vaccine is now available in places
like florida to everybody over 18 years
of age
so we are near the end of this thing and
yet we are still seeing the symptoms of
coveted insanity everywhere
and it's being treated as as some sort
of normal
like the new normal is coveted insanity
this has some
real world consequences and people are
quite sick of it the tape that was made
around yesterday is from spirit airlines
where they kicked a family off because a
two-year-old
would not wear a mask by the way this is
a family you can tell is an orthodox
jewish family
um because he's wearing a yarmulke and
uh and he
has not only a special he not only has a
two-year-old who's eating
who's eating and not wearing a mask
which is okay but also a special needs
child sitting in that row
and the stewardess suggests that this
family has to be kicked off she calls
the cops and clears the plane
not compliant
the baby
she's just turned two months ago
they deplaned the entire aircraft okay
this stuff is crazy
it's crazy and you know what it's
unnecessary planes have not been a
vector for transmission
the entire time the entire time people
are not
getting this thing on planes okay that's
been true since the beginning of the
pandemic now that everybody is getting
vaccinated or everybody's already had
coveted
i mean because remember millions and
millions of americans have already had
coveted and not had the vaccine
again i was at an event over passover
where people weren't wearing masks and
if a reporter had walked in they would
be oh my god
surely this will be a hot spot except
that i asked the crowd
at one of my speeches how many of you
have already had covet or have had a
vaccine
every single hand in the audience goes
up except for a couple of parents
brought like a five-year-old and the
five-year-old didn't
didn't put his hand up okay this country
is not
in the middle of another coveted
pandemic and yet if you read the media
what you get is that the country's in
the middle of a coded pandemic which is
why we should all be panicked about
people not wearing masks
around us and the media are lying to you
about kobet right they just openly lie
60 minutes
openly lied about ron desantis they
suggested that governor desantis here in
florida took a 100
000 bribe from money into his super pac
in order to get publix to distribute the
vaccine which is insane because publix
is the number one grocery store
with 800 outlets in the state of florida
if given 1.5 million people covet shots
in the state of florida that's a bad
thing apparently
according to your mainstream media by
the way a democratic mayor of palm beach
county
he said that this is nonsense he says i
watched the 60-minute segment on palm
beach county last night and feel
compelled to issue this statement
the reporting was not just based on bad
information it was intentionally false
i know this because i offered to provide
my insight into palm beach county's
vaccination efforts and 60 minutes
declined they know the governor came to
palm beach county and met with me
and the county administrator and we
asked to expand the state's partnership
with publix to palm beach county
we also discussed our own local plans to
expand mass vaccination centers
throughout the county
which the governor has been incredibly
supportive of we asked he delivered they
had that information they left it out
because it kneecaps their narrative that
is the democratic mayor of palm beach
county
dave kerner he's a democrat hey the
media are so focused in on the biden
administration narrative that the
pandemic is endless which is why we have
to spend
oodles and oodles of money and build
back better
they're so focused on that that they're
just completely willing to override
reality
it's amazing by the way what are the
real world impacts of this
how about this yesterday the los angeles
public health division
issued their daily update from april 5th
there were 366
new cases in l.a county which is a
county of 10
million people how many new deaths were
there
one one new death in l.a county
okay which is again a county of 10
million people
they close outdoor dining in la county
this is crazy and there is going to be a
backlash and the backlash is going to be
severe it's going to be real and it's
going to be severe which is why
harry enten got himself in all sorts of
trouble yesterday for pointing out the
obvious he had a piece
over at cnn pointing out the early signs
are very good for the gop in 2022.
he says president joe biden's first two
and a half months in office have been
far better received than former
president donald trump's
biden's been able to maintain an
approval rating north of 50 yet a look
at the data
also reveals that biden's democratic
party has likely not picked up any
support since the election if historical
trends hold
democrats are likely going to face a
rough political environment in the
midterms
one of the best ways to judge the
political environment is through the
generic congressional ballot
the generic ballot asks respondents some
form of the following question
if the elections for congress were held
today would you vote for the democrats
or the republicans
democrats are ahead on that measure by
about four points in the average poll
taken
since the beginning of biden's
administration that lead is about the
same as the final margin in the 2020
presidential race
and in the 2020 house popular vote
this tends to line up with what we have
seen in terms of party identification
remember the 2020 polls tended to
underestimate the republican position
which means
republicans are actually doing better on
the generic ballot now than they were
heading into the 2020 election
additionally the types of voters will be
casting a ballot in 2022 will likely be
more favorably disposed to the gop than
the overall voting population
the reason is that when there's a
democrat in the white house republicans
have a turnout advantage
a study i did back in 2018 says harry
enten who's formerly at 538
reveals that voters who turned out in
midterms with democratic presidents were
more republican-leaning than registered
voters at large in every single midterm
since 1978.
on average in these midterms the gap
between the registered voter and the
actual electorate
had been about five points more
republican among the actual electorate
justifying that shift to the polling now
it's not hard to imagine that
republicans may already have an
advantage with the voters who will turn
out next year
of course it's possible the cycle could
be different
it's likely however there will be some
movement toward the republicans in the
national political environment between
now
and next november the party not in
control of the white house has done
worse in the national house vote
than they have than they were doing on
the generic ballot at this point in 12
of 14 midterm elections for which we
have polling at this point
the only exceptions were 1974 when
democrats already had a large lead
in 2002 when polling didn't take into
account september 11th
once you control for who controls the
white house there's a surprisingly
strong correlation
between the generic congressional ballot
19 months before the midterm elections
and the eventual house results
if trends hold the likely national house
results in 2022 given the current
generic ballot is republicans winning
by between four and five points
so it would be a historical anomaly for
republicans not to win back the house
in the next election cycle right so this
notion that democrats
are always and forever going to be on
the on the move here it's just not true
in the same way that it was not true in
after barack obama won a sweeping
victory and you can tell the democrats
are starting to run scared here one of
the ways you can tell the democrats are
starting to run scared
is that joe biden is now backing off of
his own push for mlb to move the
all-star games you remember he went on
espn
with the reporter sage steele and sage
asked him
about by the way she put out a tweet
saying she disagreed with him on this
so just worth noting sage steel asked
him
you know should mlb move the all-star
game he said i would i would back that
well now that stacey abrams was pointing
out to joe biden and company that you
just alienated a huge percentage of
georgians with this nonsense
now biden's trying to back off of it
according to politico
when biden was asked last week what he
thought of major league baseball moving
its all-star game he told espn he would
strongly support them doing that
on friday the league announced it would
hold the game elsewhere and by the way
invoked biden
in their actual press release asked
during the briefing whether biden
supported the league's decision
saki re-read biden's remarks and
distanced the president from the boycott
she said he wasn't dictating what major
league baseball should do
he supports them being able to make that
decision okay that is just revisionist
history
the democrats might be starting to
realize that it's a bad idea
to be this crazy they might be beginning
to realize that there will be a backlash
to all of this and by the way the
backlash might be much stronger
in terms of both the law and in terms of
politics
then anybody on the left is willing to
contemplate
one of the areas of backlash could
theoretically be
going after facebook twitter and google
justice clarence thomas
had a concurrence in a recent supreme
court case on monday
in which the supreme court vacated a
lower court ruling in finding that
president trump had acted
unconstitutionally by blocking people on
twitter
that case which the justices de moot
hinged on the idea that the donald trump
account was a public forum run by the
president of the united states
in his concurrence justice thomas agreed
with the decision to that the case was
moved because
trump is no longer president but he
argued that twitter's recent ban of
trump's account suggests
it's the platforms themselves not the
government officials on them that hold
all the power so in other words
if you are going to treat donald trump's
twitter account
as though it is a public utility you
have to treat all of twitter like it's a
public utility
thomas wrote as twitter made clear the
right to cut off speech lies most
powerfully in the hands
of private digital platforms the extent
to which that power matters for purposes
of the first amendment
and the extent to which that power could
lawfully be modified raised interesting
and important questions
thomas said some digital platforms
basically ought to be treated like
common carriers
thomas says a traditional telephone
company laid physical wires to create a
network connecting people
digital platforms lay information
infrastructure that can be controlled in
much the same way
thomas argued that while private
companies aren't subject to the first
amendment common carriers are unique and
that they don't have the right to
exclude
he suggests that large tech platforms
with substantial market power should be
bound by the same restrictions he says
if the analogy between common carriers
and digital platforms is correct
an answer may arise for dissatisfied
platform users who would appreciate not
being blocked
laws that restrict the platform's right
to exclude so thomas is overtly now
stumping
for republicans to pass a law maybe with
some democrats
that basically say that twitter and
facebook and google can no longer
exclude people
on the basis of political bent
thomas describes the sure scope of
facebook and google's market power
citing facebook's 3 billion users in
google's 90
market share in search he says it
changes nothing these platforms are not
the sole means for distributing speech
or information
a person could always choose to avoid
the toll bridge or train and instead
swim the charles river or hike or hike
the oregon trail but in assessing
whether a company exercises substantial
market power
what matters is whether the alternatives
are comparable for many of today's
digital platforms
nothing is thomas said that it wouldn't
be a court that does this he said there
would be a legislature that does this
but he says we'll soon have no choice
but to address how our legal doctrines
apply to highly concentrated privately
owned information infrastructures
such as digital platforms here's the
bottom line the backlash is coming it's
going to come strong
people on the right are not going to sit
by for this stuff they are not they're
not going to sit by
and watch joe biden unilaterally redraw
the lines of division and demarcation
between the government and the
individual they're not going to sit by
and watch social media redraw the lines
of the first amendment they're not going
to sit by and watch democrats
redraw the nature of american freedom of
association and freedom of speech
they're not going to do any of that and
they're not going to go along with the
corporations that go along with this
there will be a backlash the backlash is
coming
and i am pleased to see that backlash
coming because nothing could be more
timely than a massive backlash against
the wild leftist overreach we are
currently seeing
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
heron makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show